[Musique]
ce choix termina j'ai suffisamment
attentifs vous pouvoir parler deuxième
question que je me pose est que les
français se posent
je trouve tout à fait curieux qu'on ait
une augmentation subite des réanimations
particulièrement l'ap-hp en ile de
france alors que l'on nous explique
donné c'est le premier point
attendez j'ai à prétention effectivement
ici je vais pas faire des choses
relativement sérieux données avec des
données sources étaient bouchés restez-y
la haute des papes fabre chose à [ __ ]
des cartes je cherche à comprendre c'est
fait je cherche à comprendre comment
est-ce que ayant des patients en soins
intensifs chercher en soi continue même
pas vrai et bien effectivement mais on
se retrouve avec on nous dit ça me
libère sa surface à l'arrière goût d'y
regarder ça sert à rien je me casserais
alors fabrice grange et non mais
attendez excusez moi mais vrai deux
minutes je suis en train de parler de
choses extrêmement sérieuses auxquelles
personne n'a répondu
ils sont même je suis en train de vous
dire que les chiffres avant avant
février 2020 ce qu'on appelait la
réanimation correspondent à une
définition donnée par la direction
générale de la santé
cette définition a changé à la faveur du
co ville monsieur nous écouter mais
rentrons pas dans une discussion
chimiques mais enfin monsieur c'est vrai
mais c'est pas vrai ce que je vous dis
écoutez si c'est vrai c'est important je
sais pas mais on verra rien décisions
importantes sont fou qu'est ce que je
cherche à chicha pourquoi elle
arrondissait penser que les chics jeux
sont bidonnés ne le pensent qu'à eux
mêmes
non mais il est juste s'est interrogé
sur le phénomène qui s'est passé en bas
de ma soeur aînée de france tout le
monde tout le monde dont la survie la
droite s'est interrogé bien sûr c'est
pas parce que ça vous appelle pour vous
prend pour le centre du monde aux
intérêts excusez moi jean monsieur si tu
veux tu as tu allais concept innovant
jean-régis excusez moi monsieur mes jeux
3d numéro 12 a rien demandé je crois que
vous avez un problème monsieur avec oui
j'ai un problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui
notre écosystème il est profondément
bouleversé et vous faites la diarrhée
verbale et cadets sont venus en aide le
corps est juridiquement vous vous
pourrez d'aidé mais qui sont bord du
gouffre des entreprises qui n'ont plus
de fonds et qui ont pu tune et qui ont
des trous dans la raquette et vous les
emmenez sur des procédures studio dit
comme ça je ne sais pas 2007 et son
process fabrice tourre attaquer nos
mines m
je dénonce croyait excusez moi je
croyais que vous croyez que j'aime a
baissé à un niveau comme ça mais je
termine je termine cette année c'est un
message envoyé est clair que la mienne
bon enfant
m